voodoo another application framework
software has expanded and refined a
foundation for a broad range of tools
used in visual effects
these include match moving match move
camera check tracking and animated
character tool sets for animation fur
muscles and more boudu was a Ryoka
texture of RIE Rhythm & Hues original
animation tool from 1988 through 1996 it
was conceived as replacing the insides
while keeping the body like voodoo since
then it has been used on groundbreaking
films like Golden Compass Chronicles of
Narnia and the oscar-winning Life of Pi
the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to Peter Wong and
Chris Perry for for their architectural
contributions and to Hans right rock
kuma and Joe man sewage before the core
engineering of Voodoo and their
application framework gentlemen please
join us for a walk Thank You Academy and
Thank You Rhythm & Hues
John Hughes Pauline Cho and keith
Goldfarb you foster the creative
environment and challenged us to build
reusable tools the arthas leverage these
tools in brilliant ways we didn't
imagine that they'd use them in and they
told magical stories my family is here I
just want to thank them for sharing this
amazing moment
to the hundreds of artists and engineers
at Rhythm & Hues whose names are not on
this award if it weren't for your
technical and creative brilliance over
the last almost 20 years now we wouldn't
be up here I want to thank Paul Newell
Keith Goldfarb and John Hughes for their
mentorship and for having their faith in
me as a young engineer who had big ideas
but not a lot of experience and finally
- my family thanks for all of a lifetime
of creative support I'd also like to
thank mr. Matt Dirksen for his
contributions from an artists
perspective he really did an exceptional
job and bringing a lot of great ideas
into our software I like to thank sherry
Brad huge for keeping the ship on a
straight course 17 years ago while I was
driving from Ann Arbor to Los Angeles
with my wife she says to me not really
understanding where I didn't understand
how these awards works she said well mr.
movie man when you win your Academy
Award you can mention me in the
acceptance speech and I never thought
the decade what happened to me but here
I am so I would like to say thank you to
her shell and to our boys Evan in Cole
for their years of support encouragement
and tolerance thank you
I would like to thank the Academy and my
wife would like to thank the Academy for
getting me to wear a tie for only the
second time in my life when we proposed
to make this a team award instead of
giving it to us for the committee rolled
their eyes and said like there's a
typical redeeming use community spirit
again save it for your acceptance speech
so here we are so I've been honored to
work with very a lot of talented artists
and programmers over the years to make
voodoo such a great tool and I hope we
can do them proud to make more people
aware of the awesomeness of voodoo in
the future but if there was a single
person that would would deserve this
award it would be John Hughes that
created this excellent environment that
instilled in us this community spirit
that made us all shine and it made us do
better work and it made us better people
so therefore John thank you very much
this one is for you